or comment tu vas
l'a72 le ta fidélité ce soir je vais
faire le petit tweet en même temps je
laisse les gens s'installer
tranquillement
je préviens tout le monde qu'on est en
live et je suis à vous
ou moi ça va trancher là écoute je suis
en vacances je vais pas me plaindre j'ai
passé mon temps à regarder tes
regarder des matchs donc que du qui aura
la famille on va se reposer et puis on
va bourriner là et prospects
alors par contre j'ai twitté avec le
comte envergure c'est mieux c'est plus
pratique tous un peu plus de monde
donc si vous arrivez vous inquiétez pas
le stream vient d'ailleurs look si tu me
dis aussi au niveau du son des ponts
voilà si vous arrivez vous inquiétez pas
je suis là c'est juste que je ressens de
faire tous les petits tweets et ses
rachats la technique en même temps
hop hop
ici ici
là donc comme je disais vous inquiétez
pas je suis bien là c'est juste que je
fais les tweets eux
ok c'est fait bon on va se voir
s'installer ensemble donc si vous avez
vu le tweet peut-être que
vous avez dû le comprendre on va parler
ce soir de villanova des wildcats et
vilanova qui ont été plusieurs fois
champion l'équipe de jay white va faire
un petit tour d'horizon
de cette équipe on va regarder j'ai pris
quatre prospects qui sont quatre des
cinq titulaires de l'année on va
regarder leurs stats on va regarder
leurs profils via envergure vient dé
cette avance etc et puis on va faire du
tue par exemple pour voir forces et
faiblesses qu'on essaie de les projeter
on n'est pas sur les énormes non glay pu
voir plusieurs fois de la prochaine
draft villanova c'est une fac sérieuse
qui met toujours des seniors donc
ne soyez pas ne soyez pas surpris alors
j'en vois trois samuel tu qu'il est psy
powell powell
non pas powell preiser ça me dit rien
donc je suis pas sûr que tu penses ou
même jour que moi alors pour être
honnête il ya passé par la ceni qui plus
est beaucoup mais quand je regarde
une équipe je vais regarder surtout des
joueurs avec mort est effectivement
moore ce style mots et on va parler d'un
an dernier qui est moins coté brendan
slater qui est le favori d'alexandre le
papa du podcast envergure quand je
regarde une équipe je rappelle à tous un
petit peu comme ça je regarde des
joueurs spécifiques j'ai regardé un mec
donc je peux très bien passé deux heures
à regarder à j'aurais pas connaître le
nom des joueurs autour d'un prêtre le
score n'ya connaître à la les stats etc
je voulais vraiment un mec seul
hop je fais les petites motif de tous
les copains
et puis je suis dit moi dans le chat en
même temps je sais pas combien on est là
actuellement j'ai pas le les chiffres
sous les yeux les quatre très bien aussi
intimiste née c'est sympa dites moi ce
que vous connaissez un petit peu de
dégâts de villanova ça m'intéresse comme
ça quelles sont leurs forces leurs
faiblesses qu'est-ce que vous avez qui
feinte la regarderai ce que signifie que
vous
vous connaissez pas du tout est ce que
c'est une équipe nous avons tendu par
aller pour les championnats les joueurs
un petit problématique qui en sortent à
l'achat peu curieux de savoir la
popularité de cette fac on parle pas
très souvent mais qui on voit tous les
ans des mecs référencé en nba
mourey samuel chute très bien ouais
effectivement ça leur clé d'entrée
principale on bravo ça ensemble saluer
lé 10 août depuis cette année seulement
justin mois un peu plus
est ce que tu sais tu regarde à présent
les années précédentes est ce qu'il ya
des mecs qui te reviennent comme ça en
tête qui sortent de cette équipe de sept
gros sécurité
et vilanova
j'essaie vraiment de faire le plus vite
possible entre eux mais natif etc je
suis désolé je suis pas expert je suis
vraiment
satisfait ouais ça dit paix tu as une à
robinson heures bronson on peut aussi
citer le plus au draft et je crois que
la fac peut-être faut que je vérifie
mais on a notre ami michael bodies qui
est parent je crois 11e place à l'époque
on n'a rien d'anti d'akono qui pige en
nba qui passait par les bulls et par
bones tonnes ensuite à connaître dive in
chains au bien sûr dotées qui se verrait
même année parmi nouveau qui je crois
qu'il part en dix septième un très beau
ce style-là
sophomore exemple du bon
voilà c'est une équipe qui en voit
surtout des représentants des joueurs
très très très intéressant
on va regarder ça alors normalement on
sait pas l'objectif en deux formats tête
de chien pour s'en fout un peu mais
normalement là vous dites à la technique
si vous me voyez toujours avec cette
cale bosch acquis et avec le temps va
tout s'en va littéralement
vous me dites justice a marché dans les
transitions et après comme ça on passe
sur les internets
c'est un petit peu vos retours on te
vois mon bas super merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup
hop toi conte et 6 ans semble donc
martin nous rejoindre comme je le dis on
va parler de villanova et on est parti
alors du coup l'objectif à la fête de
refaire un tour d'horizon de ces joueurs
là justin moore
chairman samuel salut mac
gowlings et epci et bonce lecteurs qui
sont prononcés mais comme ça les quatre
plus gros prospecte actuellement de la
fac ça luchini
bienvenue parmi nous sa première fois
donc c'est hyper plaisir noir l'ont pas
de ces quatre jours là on va faire du
bois donne on va commencer peut être par
le jour le plus évident celui qui plaît
le plus à l'équipe envergure dans le
consensus c'est notre ami justin mot
donc hop on passe là dessus et là
normalement vous devez voir la page de
justin moore qui s'affiche sur le site
envergure
le scouting airport sortira soit
dimanche choix dimanche prochain c'est
moi qui m'en occupe puisque ces deux là
la big east ce style mans vous voyez 22
ans on est sur une quatrième année à
rennes 3 3 ans ici juniors mais on va
arriver sur une quatrième année là après
celle ci reste encore un an de plus
normalement ils devraient la draft là je
pense avec 85 91 kg diack et shooting
guard la première chose qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui à steinbourg c'est qu'en nba
il devrait jouer ailier voir ailier fort
c'est en
c1 2 dommage j'aurais aimé aux catalans
n'ont battu voit justement il va jouer
ailier évier force est il arrivé en tant
que jeu steam guard est ce qu il portait
le ballon que il a toujours joué les
stars elle a même joué meneur mais en
fait il est il est très lourd il est
très puissant je pensais vraiment qu'il
était plus grand que ça quand je les ai
vus la première fois qu'il était plus
large que ça c'est vraiment à un gros
but qui me rappelle un peu sadiques paix
à son compère de villanova qui est sorti
il ya deux ans maintenant
on peut regarder un petit peu les stats
donc il arrive en 1ère année et j'ai
quand même trente minutes par match mais
il sort qu'à vos débuts du bon
initialement on avait 1 40% à 3 points
avec un beau volume 5 tentatives par
match l'an dernier baisse d'adressent on
voit trop tard pour cent mais avec un
gros volume aussi alors faut comprendre
que l'équipe ait manqué elle manquait de
rythme elle manquait de rythme aussi on
a une population majeure de monsieur guy
des psys en fin de saison qui était très
dommageable
il ya eu la station avec j'irai bien
robinson perles aussi qui a pris un peu
de temps donc 13 points et cette année
c'est le plus gros shooteur de l'équipe
c'est le plus gros volume de tir c'est
lui le patron de l' attaque alors que
c'est pas le plus âgé 15,6 points mais
sans encore on s'en fout un peu s'y
tient tentatives à trois points par
match comme on peut le voir là j'espère
que c'est assez gros pour vous 38% de
moins sur un beau volume 1 très douteux
70% lancers francs avec un tout petit
volume on va reparler et 44% en général
ce que j'aime beaucoup chez ce joueur
c'est qu'il est complet on voit 5,5
passes on voit cinq robots excusez-moi
trois passes une formule de style là
c'est un joueur très polyvalent zuma
plus sur les stats bien sûr bien sûr
merci à vraiment n'hésitez pas à me
faire des retours moi je suis là pour ça
j'ai le chat sous les yeux est lâchée
sur l'onglet internet
voilà donc nous ce qui ne va nous
intéresser cette année pour la clé en
juillet c'est ce 38% de loin et surtout
pareille fortune en sautant du pont sont
de loin et se 5,5 route
donc pour un peu et dans les stats
avancé avant que je vous envoie ce qui
me plaît plus - la vidéo on est ici
chapelle ou peaux mates je vous aime ça
fait un peu trop doux mais vous n'êtes
pas les papilles
on est sûr ou pote point com n'hésitez
pas à utiliser ce site là ça vous permet
d'avoir les ça va avancer des joueurs
notamment sur la pourcentage de réussite
près du cercle que vous avez là le
nombre de tirs tentés dans ce secteur à
chaque fois ce qui laisse supposer une
passe décisive cern l'excellent site que
j'utilise tout le temps
très très complet et qui se met vite à
jour justin meurt comme on l'a vu là
vous avez tout profit de l'équipe les
4000 noms parlent aujourd'hui ils sont
là c'est les quatre premiers moore qui
les psys samuel et sly que c'est le plus
gros volume
on a comme on le disait 38% des tirs à
trois points 71 % seulement qui sont en
cas de chutes issues d'une passe
décisive
donc ça veut dire qu'on a un jour qu'il
prend quand même pas mal de poules up
jusqu'au moindre happant nba c'est là
quasiment la moitié de ces tiers on est
vraiment sûr l'archétype de ce qu'on
aime bien un billet je prends des tirs
près du cercle 51% réussite ça assez
faible par contre je prends beaucoup de
tirs à trois points et là dessus je suis
efficace d'accord on voit aussi ici que
ça un joueur qui lorsqu il va au panier
attaquer le cercle génère dans 19% des
temps des lancers francs c'est assez
faible pour vous donner un ordre d'idée
voyez ses copains qui sont pas les plus
athlétiques 23 30 % donc voilà 18 %
c'est vraiment vraiment très léger on
peut compléter et après j'arrête avec
les chiffres parce que je sais que c'est
pas le truc le plus drôle mais ça donne
un bon point dépendants les profils ce
site la soupe explorer ça alex andreu
qui me l'a filé je trouve très
intéressant aussi
des avec des codes couleurs des façons
de comparer de façon assez intuitive
notre ami justin mort il est là on va
regarder rapidement tirs à trois points
38 % de réussite donc c'est bien
arrachant la moyenne n 6 et ça ça
m'intéresse
e
c'est 40 1 37e on l'a vu c'est dans la
moyenne
il vaut au niveau de l'envié c'est la
moyenne haute par contre près du panier
ça comptait 1 % seulement de près du
panier ça s'est passé fait bloc on a un
joueur qui tire très bien de loin qui
est un peu plus on galère près du panier
et qui existe pas mal à mi-distance et
maintenant on va regarder pourquoi avec
du fil
je vous avais pas le film comme ça alors
hop hop ici je vous ai préparé le film
enfants petite playlist de clips on va
regarder les clips va regarder avoue fur
et à mesure les points forts points
faibles etc on va faire du ralenti je
voulais me dans l'ordre quelle entrée
tirs à trois points deuxième clé
d'entrée la défense notamment la défense
collective il faut tout ce qui va être
la rotation le rebond et caetera et
enfin il est entre guillemets plus ce
qui peut faire de un peu mieux et puis
les défauts donc on est parti pour
monsieur turmel n'importe quoi justin
moore si vous avez des questions
toujours pareil n'hésitez pas surtout si
vous rejoignez en plein milieu moi je
suis là pour ça hop on est parti je
regarde ces motions et bien minutes
alors on se l'ardent city je place en
plein écran le son et minutes c'est
parfait donc justin moore alors la
qualité n'est pas forcément incroyable
on est sur du captur 480p 720p youtube
c'est le joueur de petits porteurs des
numéros 5 d'accord pour avoir un point
de repère dû serrer toujours tout le
pointer c'est le guardian numéro 5 ici
on va tourner d'abord le tir à trois
points comme je vous le disais donc les
mains elles sont près de me positionne
je déclenche assez rapidement achever
ficelles donc on a vu 38% du de réussite
on va regarder un petit peu ralenti le
placement est intéressant la vitesse est
intéressante aussi sa part assez vite
adelina elles sont prêtes je suis bien
placé je remonte nous tirait à céaucé à
ses propres marques est assez bon aussi
je fais ficelles voilà ce qu'on peut
attendre justin moore au niveau
supérieur deuxième exemple de catch and
shoot leur base dans le corner il est là
les masses sont prêtes et tout de suite
je déclenche rapidement un trois points
on va se la mettre une petite fois
au ralenti regardez les mains sont
prêtes hop je monte donc la jouer contre
une défense de zone la corée dans lequel
elle a eu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup
prêt pour le tir à trois points même un
peu éloigné du circuit la distance
éloignée au niveau de la ligne c est
pour ceux qui savent pas la ligne si
elle est plus proche que la ligne et le
biais nous on aimerait bien que que ça
se soit équilibré le filet mais il ya
aussi des joueurs qu'on va voir qu'ils
vont jouer en europe donc pourquoi pas
mais voilà c'est toujours intéressant
encore garde un shooter c'est le volume
il faut un gros volume la distance on
aime bien les joueurs qui prennent
distance nba donc au moins un pas
derrière la ligne à trois points de 6è
et la vitesse d'exécution pour pouvoir
exister et les joueurs qui tire à trois
points l'an dernier le magasin me sens
très très lent donc c'est pas une menace
la situation où je pars a dream je peux
cugnière on n'entendra pas forcément nba
mais toujours intéressant on est très
loin ces prêts avec confiance justin
mort on l'a vu 70% de 100 foot 30% de
poules up voilà souvent un petit dribble
et je vais prendre un petit poulet pas
trois points j'ai pu lire çà en nba
peut-être qu'il l'aura il n'aura pas
beaucoup mais c'est toujours une arme
supplémentaire
ici on va être maintenant sur la
séquence défensive de justin moore
ce que j'aime bien c'est que c'est un
joueur qui est tout le temps très actif
toujours très bien placé on les choix du
produit villanova on va se faire faire
on est sur des produits villanova
nothing équipe qui switch to une équipe
qui est très collective on est beaucoup
dans l'aide lui et regarde l'action il
décroche pas de son défenseur à jour qui
est rarement perdu sur le terrain et il
ya toujours faire une bonne route à pour
couper avec des maxi vance l'art fait au
ralenti
l' issue l'action il regarde si son
joueur il se démarque pas parce qu'on a
à shooter dans le numéro 11 c'est la
star de l'équipe qui part au drive et je
viens tout de suite faire la rotation
des mains active je sauve le ballon
j'aime là les réflexes ici aussi voilà
ça aurait dit on va beaucoup l'attendent
c'est un joueur on disait ah mais 95 20
on peut se retrouver le bon physique à
20 84 91 kg qui va en nba défendre des
postes 3 des postes 4 et aussi quelques
arrière pour les arrières - les moins
explosif mais c'est surtout à défenseur
délit donc toutes les équipes chargées
nélias oui elle dit là on a un très très
bon profil on est reparti je passe en
vitesse normale on est encore chaude la
séquence défensive
hop tout de suite je viens dans la
rotation alors ça la coupe est forcément
regarder je viens directement est comme
ça je viens place tenait sous le panier
et ensuite utile en transition
il a des très bons réflexes des très
bons instincts défensif c'est ça qu'on
aime beaucoup tout de suite je vois
qu'il ya un trou je viens comblé je
reste verticale mes mains sont actives
il a le copain samuel on va parler après
il ya une transition paniers faciles là
on va regarder le bac ça tu regardais la
prise de position là je crois qu'il boxe
à turin post 4 postes 5 à plus de deux
mètres 0 joseph ont vérifié
beaucoup dans le bas du corps c'est un
joueur qui est très puissant en bas du
corps on utilise les bras la position on
sait que la balle on va sûrement aller
dans cette direction et on obtient son
mec jusqu'aux quarts de la suite de
l'action je reste bien dans son dos là
ça rentre mais s'il y avait eu rebonds
je leur ai vus ils peuvent parfaire du
coup en vitesse normale
tout simplement c'est que c'est le genre
de choses très très bête mais
qui ont de la valeur pour une équipe nba
quand vous allez acheter un profil de
souffle il dit vous allez acheter un
package complet si un mec qui peut
prendre des rebonds voici 5 rebonds
c'est hyper intéressant pour sa taille
sa joie que je vois très rarement battu
sur le rebond défensif alors que
l'équipe joue petit avec un pivot qui
est là vous voyez qui vraiment pas très
grand je pense qu'on a de 0,3 de 0,5 et
clôt balmont à cinq mecs qui font 1,95
de m quoi
et lui à l'image de son équipe est un
très très bon rebondeur encore une fois
les mains sont actives ici
autre séquence regarder comment on est
en protection de l'armée pardon
vous me dites ah s'il faut que j'arrête
je veux aller plus vite ou quoi mais
on va être tout le long en protection de
son rebond défensif
regardez le joueur et on va sécuriser
enlève pas prendre de positions ça fait
vraiment très football américain ici
regardez hop je vois qu'il ya un tir je
couvre je couvre je bloque avec mes bras
je prends la prise de position j'ai une
transition et après
pour mon équipe
on se remet ici en vitesse réelle donc
maintenant on va passer plus peut-être
sur les choses bonus que peut nous faire
justin moore là on le voit balle en main
après un dribble je m'approche du cercle
et je finis ma droite alors il un
dribble très caractéristique je vais
vous le mettre en en vraiment lent la
plupart des joueurs qu'on va considérer
comme des porteurs de ballon et n'diaye
ou
un dribble plutôt classique qui changent
de mains ils ont ils accélèrent ils
peuvent ouais accéléré ils peuvent
ralentir ils peuvent changer la longueur
de leurs dribbles peuvent comme je dis
changé de main et cetera pour ce qui est
des décalages testing moore pas du tout
il joue meneur de jeu depuis longtemps
mais lui il est vraiment fort sa
supériorité physique
on à l'épaule du coup qu'il avait du
bras qui ne porte pas le ballon en avant
on a le bras qui n'ont pas de ballons le
off and pour repousser et on y va
vraiment en puissance vous allez voir
y'a rien d'esthétique c'est de la pure
prise de puissance nature domination
physique sur son adversaire direct
regardez-moi ça on 05 donc la technique
les six pick and roll voilà mon bras
couvre et j'ai avancé tu peux rien faire
parce que je suis trop grand registre
ans je suis trop puissant je suis trop
lourd et je vais aller jusqu'au terme et
trouver la faute on a un joueur on l'a
vu avec peu d'efficacité près du panier
51% parce que c'est pas le plus gros
athlètes dans le premier pas c'est pas
le meilleur haendel s'est pas non plus a
fait le plus vertical message aux requis
de lune physiquement qui est puissant
qui se créent un accès au panier en nba
y aura pas forcément beaucoup de
situations et sera porteur de balle mais
j'aime bien sûr un renversement avoir ce
joueur qui est fort qui peut aller sur
un cut de dribble tout en puissance
finir au panier et c'est là dessus qu'on
va l'attendre ça ça lui donne un bonus
par rapport à quelques autres joueurs
qui sont vraiment que dès ce week end
la gent reversement la main elle est
prête petite feinte de droite petites
faims de départ à gauche et je vais tout
en puissance finir au panier et provoqué
une faute on revoit je refais dribble
vraiment voilà c'est alors effectivement
vous l'avez au ralenti mais c'est pas du
tout est explosif on est sur des
fondamentaux de pied main gauche le bras
qui protège le ballon
vraiment tout en butant en puissance
brute et je vais au panier ici on a du
contrôle de son dribble on se met pas en
danger il ya un écart sur pick'n roll
chose une défense de zone je peux plus
la famille distance justin moore est un
joueur qui peut aussi fonctionner mi
distance qui peut aussi un peu joué du
pick and roll et qu'ils un très bon
shooteur dans l'espace intermédiaire
bien peu de volume
mais on voit que voilà ça remette qui à
l'aise qui assez complet je vous le
remet en vitesse réelle parce que je
trouve ce clip intéressant nous vous
voyez on est face à syracuse donc c'est
la bonne vieille jonas le coach brahim
fait depuis maintenant je suis pas 30 40
ans je sais plus combien de temps ils
exercent avec deux de ses fils dans
l'équipe ça c'est le comme on dit les
petits de despotisme
voilà on rentre mes distances on le voit
encore un dribble avec le bras en avant
je pilote distance d'un corps voyez
difficultés dans son dribble je suis pas
explosif j'arrive pas à me créer un
décalage chimie parra pull-ups il allait
rentrer mais globalement on n'est pas
sûr rare sur vraiment un arrière fuite
balle en main en nba je vais pas lui
demander d'être un créateur initiateurs
ici ce que j'aime bien hop c'est encore
une fois la manipulation on sait que
c'est il sait que c'est pas un athlète
donc j'aurais pu utiliser puisqu'il
arrive à se créer des décalages
regardez ici
on est je donne une feinte et je passe à
gauche et je vais finir voilà on vous
voyait le score ont des fins de joseph
c'est pas une grande équipe en face à on
est à 29 51 mais ce qui m'a intéressé
les fondamentaux de pied encore chez
sony on a des joueurs avec des bons
fondamentaux on a fait trois ans dans le
parcours n 6 et
qui peuvent tout de suite servir vos
pieds
ouais c'est vrai vide et ils sont 1 3
depuis deux trois matches il modifie pas
mal syracuse je pense que ils ont fraudé
des gros gros gros athlètes un peu un
peu tank et avec pas forcément beaucoup
de talent là on a dans le numéro un gros
shooter on allait bohème qui sont des
gros shooteur donc on est plus sur le
on est plus sur le choix de la longueur
plutôt que de la puissance brute c'est
vrai que la 2nd elle a un peu modifié sa
luge festival comment tu vas bah écoute
ça va très très bien de notre côté on
est chauds du clip de jours de villanova
on commence par justin mourchidates le
prospect le plus côté de l'équipe et
puis on va faire le tour des quatre
joueurs donc elle n'hésite pas nous dire
ce que tu en penses là on est encore sur
un pick and rolls à switch en face
j'utilise mon bras voyez on est on s'en
cache même pas ça pourrait quasiment
faire faute offensive eux s'ils vendent
ému le truc on va mettre un gros coup de
bras en mode pour freiner un espace
parce qu'on n'est pas explosif
et sur un joueur qui a pas une très
grosse littéralité j'arrive pas à me
trouver mon décalage et ça ça pose
problème pour ensuite un joueur nba pour
un créateur on est vraiment sûr plus un
rôle de finisseur
feinte de tir parce que je suis le 9 à
trois points est ce que j'aime bien
c'est que c'est un passeur fonctionnel
alors vous voyez là passez à la fête à
demain peu seul à refaire
alors j'aimerais remettre ici pardon je
reçois le ballon je crois que là parce
que l'aléa demain parce que c'est pas un
énorme eu un énorme créateur collectif
et tout je me repositionne les bras sont
prêts je peux repartir autre fait on
fait le même ou de voix d'affilée la
défense tombe deux fois cette fois-ci
guy les psys trois points et safra fils
alors je l'écouté parce que ce qui
m'intéressait c'était monsieur moore
s'est extrait l'âme et
et voilà on est sur du joueur de
villanova très fonctionnel encore une
fois
qui va toujours trouver le bon
coéquipier mais on a aussi un passeur
qui peut passer sur pick'n roll une
passe au sol je crois qu'on la voit ici
voilà petit pas seul pour son pivot
bonne lecture de jeu très patient parce
que je suis lent donc j'ai déjà joué
dans mes forces je leur fait la lecture
de pick and roll
là j'ai un petit espace et tout de suite
se transmet à mon intérieur alors dicté
pour moi pas à l'intérieur de niveau nba
peut-être un jour qui pourrait jouer
pour l'europe et encore je trouve assez
limité sur un mec nba tu ça fait deux
cas sans aucun problème ou au moins ça
fait une faute
en transition
un peu de jeu post pas parce que je suis
plus gros parce que j'ai un avantage
encore une fois ce bras of arms qui
permet de faire un petit écart pourra
rouler main gauche ce qui m'intéresse
ici c'est que c'est un joueur qui peut
finir aussi de sa main gauche alors il
est à l'aise avec les les deux côtés
pour partir en dribble pas varié son
dribble il peut passer demain il peut
finir aussi dès demain donc ça pourra
jouer une bille on va attendre aussi de
ce côté là
et là on est revenue sur 400 ch de quoi
on a fait le tour du film je vais vous
le laisser tourner pendant que qu'on en
parle et je vais vous au petit petite
question si vous en avez
on est reparti pour lancer du film voilà
justin mans vous l'avez compris on a un
joueur troisième année
qui est déjà assez assez mûr dans son
dans son jeu et dans son physique donc
ya pas un gros obstacle c'est un joueur
qui va faire du catch and shoot et qui
va défendre qu'il va défendre comme
maladie des telliers qui va défendre
loin du ballon qui aura toujours une
plus value qui va vous apporter des
rebonds c'est du soulier le 10
juillet avec un bon pourcentage en à 38%
pour la projection je sais pas où vous
l'achetez moi je peux l'avoir sur une
fin de premier tour à partir de là
je parle on va partir enfin peut-être le
plus haut possible jusqu'à 45 c'est vrai
une fourchette assez large colonne
on peut l'acheter parce que ça va un
jour qu'il va forcément avoir un impact
positif dans une équipe sur envergure
n'a pas mal de gens qui pensent en
quasiment de monde pense que ça pourra
pas être un créateur on est assez
d'accord là dessus parce qu'il ya un
manque athlétique comme on l'a vu il ya
un manque d'aisance balemagna manque
de fluidité dans le mouvement mais c'est
un jour ce qui sur un renversement peut
être utile
n'hésitez pas si vous avez dans les
petites questions là squitieri porte
s'en sortira d'ici
d'ici dix jours encore max thommes je
vous remets les stades pour ceux qui
viennent d'arriver j'estime moore pour
l'instant dans les modes draft gellé vu
vraiment aussi je les ai vu certains
l'avoir assez haut donc des vins et puis
j'ai vu certains ne pas l'avoir drafté
du tout et pas mal de gens qui préfèrent
son compère germaine samuel moi mon
préféré des deux seymour parce que ils
tirent depuis longtemps je suis plus
confiant dans le comprendre je suis plus
confiant dans le dans le tir et je suis
plus confiant c'est dans le profil
physique
il ya un antécédent de blessure janvier
justine mort qui je crois juste que
notre outil important je crois que c'est
un genou il s'est déjà fait les croisés
quand il était au lycée ce qui peut
expliquer
ce manque de puissance explosive premier
pareil de verticalité une équipe qui
leur a fait une équipe qui
est déjà compétitif c'est une équipe qui
veut un shooter for à de rotation qui
veut pouvoir avoir un mec vétérans on
pense forcément du coup l'écart fait
aller qui manquent de tir et toutes les
équipes veulent à justin mort parce que
ça coûte pas cher un contrat en fin de
premier tour second tour on est hautain
autour de 1 million emilio 5,2 millions
pour un mec qui peut arriver contribué
directement c'est du pain béni je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des 30 franchises
nba on leur propose ce jour là ils le
prennent maintenant la question c'est de
savoir est-ce qu'il ya mieux ou pas au
même endroit mais quand tu sens à un
shooter et qui défend pour les deux tu
va très très vite cher justin mans je
pense dans la prochaine draft moi si
vous avez des noms qui vous reviennent
avant mais
globalement je pense que ça des premiers
teams
cimetière en tête sachant que je passe
des mots shediac badji plus au cada
richmond petit shoot moins bien donc
voilà n'hésitez pas à donner des notes
pendant que je bascule sur le deuxième
joueur et
on en discute ensemble
opte ici à rien on va passer sur le
deuxième en même temps
alors le deuxième on l'a vu ici
souvent plus cotés que justin moore
c'est germaine samuel ce qui est son
compère qui lui pour le coup est à sa
cinquième année comment on va voir je
vais vous mettre les stats aussi
germaine samuel qu'il troisième plus
gros volume de l'équipe l'on passe sur
son profil envergure alors
ça c'est peut-être le petit des feux
nôtre c'est qu'on peut pas faire une
recherche rapide
donc vous allez forcément à voir le
côté
le côté recherche un petit peu plus
longue en attendant je mets la calvitie
pour vous mettiez une tête sur cette
voie
peut-être que vous entendez maintenant
depuis un plus un peu un peu de temps je
suis envergure
alors notre miss germany
samuel
et on est parti pour le copain germaine
s'amuse donc vous le voyez les rats ils
exultent les comptes en intermède samuel
23 ans on échouera cinquième année vous
voyez fin quand c'est un ailier 2 m 01
99 kg l'envergure
la gelée pas tout de suite mais je suis
peut-être qu'elle doit dans le scouting
les portes on échoue encore quand même
positive mais je crois de 0,6 tête de
0,8 de mémoire alors 5 ans pourquoi
parce que cette année les
joueurs qui ont terminé leur cursus de
temps a manqué quatre au maximum ont le
droit de faire une cinquième année à
cause de la pandémie qui a raccourci de
façon assez drastiques
la saison 2009 2019 2020 et 2020 2021 du
coup en compensation la plupart des des
joueurs quatrième année qui partent pour
professionnels peuvent faire une
cinquième année sans aucun problème
intermède samuel vous voyez au début il
jouait pas du tout en première année il
avait fait une grosse pub ces jeunes 23
pour un super senior non oui oui c'est
assez jeune pour un super senior 23 ans
convoyaient crise ouverte et l'an
dernier je crois avait déjà 24 on verra
garder mes docs oui c'est assez jeune
pour un super senior c'était pas un
prospect très côté german samuel
il arrive en 1ère année il fait un super
match enfin une forme très gros match
puisqu'il avait une blessure et a
presque un peu redescendue au niveau de
la hype il sait plus installé en
deuxième année quand il servait dans le
non cinq majeur avec 22 minutes pour 6
points restent sûrs des stats un peu
complète 6 points 5 rebonds une passe et
cette année et l'an dernier c'était
devenu un des patrons de l'équipe donc
on voit on se prend cette année ici
6,3 rebonds plus gros rebondeur que
notre ami justin morrow
6,2 passes 0,5 style 0,2 à kiel un peu
partout on est sur des pourcentages
ce qui est un peu nouveau règlement de
samuel c'est surtout depuis les deux
dernières années du tir à trois points
même si là il commence sur des sur des
bases assez faible avec 1 31% qui a sévi
l'an
mais voilà ce qu'ils vendaient aux gens
c'est un profil aussi de swing dire
regardez ça ensemble pour vous faire les
staffs avancer très rapidement pour pas
vous y avez avec mais pour vous faire un
dieu un petit point quand même de départ
on a un joueur qui est très efficace pas
très efficace qui est efficace près du
cercle 61 points 3 % comme on le voit
ici
on est dans le dans la moyenne haute n c
est par ici la moyenne haute nsia donc
c'est légèrement au-dessus de la moyenne
on a des stations peu plus bas si ce
n'est pas d'actualité par rapport au
dernier match qu'il a fait on est sur un
joueur qui vit uniquement sur du catch
and shoot au niveau d'un tir à trois
points c'est quasiment la moitié de son
entière et c'est 31,6 pour cent en
termes de volume je bascule on est sur
quatre tentatives par match donc ça
devient un volume intéressant pour ce
joueur là et on a un petit peu 2000
distance
avec 47% des pics à 6 sur les deux
points l'on essaie des tirs qui va créer
pour lui elle donc ça peut être aussi un
indicateur positif aux ce joueur il
arrive à se créer son décalage on va le
voir et prendre mes distances comme
justin lourds tel pourcentage aux
lancers francs assez faible c'est pas un
point commun pas mal de joueurs de
l'équipe des finales ne va que je
n'explique pas à part le fait qu'il est
vraiment basse le geste qu'on va le voir
et pas très beau et je suis runes sur
des lancers francs c'est peut-être ça se
fait un peu plus qu'il n'ya pas l'élan
donc on va pas trop du clip maintenant
avec notre ami justin monde qu'on va
offrir ça un peu là
notre mission était mort pendant 85
minutes excusez moi
comme pour justin morrow ont fait dans
l'ordre ces coiffeurs d'entre eux
viennent billet c'est du trois points va
falloir qu'ils mettent des tirs à trois
points pour pouvoir être
être sélectionné à falloir défendre donc
on va commencer par le trois points je
suis la défense et après on verra les
points positifs et les points négatifs
de façon un peu plus plus ciblées
alors pour le rhdp sur le terrain c'est
le numéro 23 qui est ici
on est encore contre syracuse j'avais
bien aimé ce match pour clip et c'était
pratique
alors vous voyez le geste est
dégueulasse ça globalement le geste est
dégueulasse l'a pas trop modifier par
rapport à l'an dernier
c'est juste que ça rentre un peu moins
il ya eu du travail quand même de faire
dans la fluidité et la rapidité mais
c'est vraiment pas un joli geste parfait
au ralenti pour bien se brûler les yeux
donc vous allez voir le tir et les ont
poussé les paie son déséquilibre c'est
vraiment pas beau les mains sont prêtes
je suis bien placé et là hop les deux
pieds qui se croisent le tir ont poussé
on est sur un shooter du dimanche mais
comprend ce tir on est à une distance
nba et on en oublie ce qui est assez
rapides donc maintenant on se rend
compte de plus en plus que le la
mécanique est assez sûr fait enfin c'est
plus vraiment un critère décisif pour ne
pas drafté ou pas un joueur il faut que
ça rentre
on va plus regarder la vitesse c'est le
tiers par d'assez ou pas et la distance
on se refait le petit le petit croisé de
ballerines offrent eux
et ça rentre ici on est là dans le
corner les mains sont prêtes
et hop tout en pousser
encore un petit 3 points donc là
encore situation de trois points on
montre que c'est vraiment poussé les
pieds se croit cette fois ci sa banane
on a vu trop tard pour cent de réussite
donc on n'achète pas pour le côté
artistique c'est plus du picasso que une
grande oeuvre d'art mais
l'an dernier on était à 30 7% cette
année 31 % je suis rarement volume c'est
ça qu'on va garder plus
donc on se met un petit astre l on ait
la pitié drôle je ne prends pas l'écran
je vais au sarc g peut finir dès demain
cela remet tout cela mais au ralenti
donc là on a un écran qui est posée je
fais semblant de le prendre je vais au
cercle
et on finit
ce qui va ce que je dois regarder là sur
ce joueur est ce qu il peut exister en
nba là dessus ça va pas être un créateur
bâle - parce que comme vous le voyez en
vitesse réelle le premier pas est encore
une fois assez faible le dribble il
n'est pas fluide on n'a plus la capacité
chez germaine samuel de changer de mains
une fois qu'on part on pare balle en
main on ne peut pas forcément accéléré
on est très vite
en difficulté sur les équipes qui vont
switcher donc c'est plus un rôle de
finisseur par contre on a vu 61% près du
cercle
c'est un pourcentage intéressant parce
qu'on a un joueur qui a 5 ans
d'université qui est encore une fois
supérieurs physiquement ses adversaires
et qui du coup va pouvoir dominée par ça
par sa maturité dans les deux sens du
terme germaine samuel c'est un joueur
qui fait tout bien et qu'ils n'excellent
nulle part
on peut se la refaire une dernière fois
et après on passe aux groupes suivants
ont regardé la fan de départ c'est là
dessus qu'il va plus pour se créer un
décalage et j'y vais tout en puissance
sur un joueur qui est bien moins
développé que moi dans une zone on
échange des fondamentaux de pied assez
intéressant enfin des départs à
l'expérience et tout en puissance on va
au panier on peut se permettre une fois
en vitesse réelle
sur un pivot depuis le centre de la zone
qui est un peu le point faible de la de
la défense de zone
pour sanctionner
donc là je réceptionne givet main gauche
et encore une fois sur un drive très
très linéaire
je vais tout en puissance au niveau du
panier regardez il n'y a pas de
variation dans le drive c'est vraiment
juste la supériorité physique donc moi
les sh finisseur direction puisque je
suis un créateur
là on a un cut et on va au cercle alors
quand je vous dis que c'est pas un
athlète ça c'est quelque chose qui est
problématique sur un joueur qui va
pouvoir faire un démarquage mois du
ballon il est assez con pour ses marques
et loi du ballon mais comme on n'a pas
un athlète verticale donc qui peut
monter très haut pour finir fort on va
souvent à voir ce genre de situation il
va star bloqué à l'arrivée sans pouvoir
créer il faut toi ou un panier au
pourcentage donc regarder le démarquage
il est bon mais comme je monte pas très
tôt que la défense elle est en place je
me fais bloqué n'y a pas de faute de
rire
ici mais marées sont prêtes
je suis dans le centre
jeu dans une fente feinte et là par
contre un bon passeur alors là dessus
c'est peut-être un des meilleurs joueurs
du championnat pour les pour les passes
au sol il est très bon pour passer au
niveau des eaux au sol c'est un passeur
fonctionnel qui fera toujours du bien
dans une une attaque placée je met en
vitesse réelle son pivot se démarque est
tout à fait trouver la passe à demain
ses assurés saccadé milk et ça
fonctionne
maintenant dans défensivement
comme le copain justin morrow un joueur
qui bac soit qui expliquerait bien son
dock sait très bien se placer et s'il ne
capte pas le rebond ils offrent leurs
boissons dites ips a fait quelque chose
que les franchises nba vont vouloir
acheter juste un joueur qui rend une
défense meilleures places qui permet de
concrétiser la défense avec un rebond à
la fin
regardez le placement du dos lamarre hop
je vais pousser dans le dos j'empêche la
défense de prendre là c'est mon copain
arcidiacono martin akono petit frère qui
récupère le rebond et qui va pouvoir
lancer la contre attaque on est encore
sur un bac saout lâchera pivot je place
mon corps je ne suis pas le plus
verticale mais je sécurise la prive pour
brawn spliter à refaire
et à des vraiment le travail au niveau
des bras au niveau des appuis en bas
pour sécuriser
il ya une troisième sera encore sur un
pivot
je prends position avec mon bras
et je crée
un rebond défensif
c'est peut-être pour les jours de sa
tanière des meilleurs rebondeurs
défensif du pays
donc là on a une défense mans du ballon
je raconterai alors vous voyez là pas la
tête au certains comme ozzy
mais serge roques est toujours très bien
placé
on va pas monter très haut mais on est
vertical et on peut poser une aide loin
du ballon
pour combler un trou en nba ce que c'est
ça qui nous intéresse en nba on va avoir
un joueur qui sera placé sur les ailiers
sûrement
sur le moins bon ailier porteur de balle
qui va beaucoup trop dans mon
orientation de son ailier parce qu'il a
des fous de latéralité qui sera toujours
bien placé dans les aides soit pour les
interceptions soit pour un bloc ça pour
un passage en force moi j'aime pas le
point de départ
comment je viens vite récupéré le mont
attaquant
pour contribuer à la
situation suivante
les mâles sont actives
on est dans l'orientation
pour venir contester vous voyez on n'est
pas sur un joueur qui va coller son
porteur de balle on est plus sur un
joueur qui va
orienter fortement jeu suivant une
direction la direction que la défense
elle elle veut donner et on va l'amener
jusque ici lorsque le défense parc
lorsque porteur de balle ne crée pas de
changements de rythme en direction bruno
donc pas non plus il pourrait passer
main droite il mettrait dans le vent
vraiment on va l'orienter l'accompagner
jusqu'au bout là où la défense elle est
placée pour pouvoir
finir la possession de l'attak
je la mène jusqu'au bout je crée pts
fait pas faute et je tiens mon porteur
de a à z
est-ce que là après les pros transition
nous voilà bolets les lignes de drive et
je vais finir tranquillement on peut le
voir exister là dedans c'est pas c'est
pas spectaculaire mais c'est juste
propres
alors voilà maintenant quand je vous
disais sur les changements de direction
il est perdu
c'est pour ça qu'il peut pas switcher
sur les extérieurs donc là pourtant on
n'a pas à l extérieur il pas explosif on
a un brahim
donc un des deux fils du coach je sais
plus si c'est pas celui qui a transféré
je crois qu'il y avait beau dit qu'ils
étaient là avant qui ici est que lui
c'est le deuxième cas transféré depuis
une on est une des facs
ivy league la ligue d'arthur quillan
marmotte aulas mais bref c'est juste du
détail là vous allez voir on va avoir un
changement de direction et il va être
mis dans le vent de chairman samuel et
ce en nba je vois des extérieurs il se
fera avoir à chaque fois donc de
souvenirs ray on part à droite et la
juste un dribble simple je pars à gauche
et voiliers comment il va déjà être mis
dans le vent on a déjà du retard ici
là je suis passé là en nba
ce sera puni systématique
autre difficulté donc là je pense qu'on
attend d'un dans un cat ligne de fond et
je pense qu'on va avoir un défaut de
deux parties qualité encore
donc je me replace
je lis bien voilà au niveau du cadre où
il se démarque bien mais je suis pas un
gros athlètes et je me fais bloqué
par la défense qui est placé donc en
vitesse réelle ils montrent pas où ils
montent pas au et du coup il se fait il
va se faire attraper par une vie ça va
aussi lui arriver là c'est pareil
st-joseph donc on n'a pas trop de balles
extra dominant mais le petit changement
de direction
va le mettre en difficulté il faut
l'armée depuis le début
je crois qu'on a une fan de départ à
gauche parce qu'il n'a rien fait à
droite et hop on repart à droite
accélérations et les parcs du laurier
une bonnette de son pivot
passage en force mais lui était battu
ici
on a encore pris latéralement on a
encore plus latéralement il ya quasi
rien quoi donc moi je suis assez inquiet
porter remède samuel va le voir quand je
fais vers la projection mais j'ai assez
inquiet pour le voir vraiment existé
plus que sur un rôle de remplaçant
plaçage sur le hand est défensive
et là on était
et vous voyez les pailles pierrick petit
à l'écran donc encore une fois il
refusant à dire parce qu'en nba il
pourra pas le refuser je suis à trois
points j'ai mon circuit derrière l'écran
il leur a pas plu il n'y aura pas mieux
que ce à quoi à part de l'afub bout de
chaîne mais là-dessus doit prendre ce
tir il le refuse l'essai pas un assez
bon athlète pour aller jusqu'au panier
donc une passe voilà bah dites moi ce
que vous pensez de domaine samuel s'est
pas fait forcément le profil le plus
le plus flatteur pour ce joueur mais
au terme de projection moi je vois plus
un second tour voire une draft il c'est
un joueur intelligent qui aura un impact
positif mais qui ne pourra pas exister
contre les meilleurs porteurs de balle
adverse qui pourra pas switcher sur tous
les profils qui pourra pas
il pourra pas glissé de l'attaquant
oranje rôle de finisseur et pour le
moment vous voyez
31,6 pour cent seulement c'est pas
suffisant on en avait 37 % donc ça c'est
intéressant mais pour un volume
un peu petit là il faut faire mieux que
ça il l'est encore côté je les vues sur
des fins de 1er tour il faudra faire
bien mieux que ça pour pouvoir avoir une
chose d'existant nba charlène samuel
s'il est pas au moins 35% 36% je n'ai
pas sur un terrain une bille et
dites moi ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires je suis un petit tweet de
rappels pour dire qu on est toujours en
stream
up et je vais vous lire juste après
de prospects
ok excusez moi je suis à vous
en défense sur le porteur c'est chaud un
peu alors voir après voilà j'ai pas pris
les exemples les plus flatteurs pour
notre ami tir de samuel danger pas été
hyper sympa j'aurais pu mettre plein de
bonnes défenses qui fait parce que
global moyen d'impact positif mais sur
des extérieurs sur des forges au r'n'b
et peuvent changer le rythme même sur
des ailiers qui peuvent changer de
rythme il va être vite en difficulté
donc je préfère vous faire un truc un
peu peut-être pessimistes en vous
montrant des fois où il fait battre
plutôt que vous vendre un prospect
défensif plus plus plus comme vous allez
l'avoir chevrier spin parce que c'est
pas la réelle était de son niveau
supérieur en réalité si on envoyait en
europe ce serait un excellent défenseur
en europe parce qu'on a des
profils atypiques ou moins explosif sur
les jours des premiers départs et tout
ça mais la nba dans une ligue où on va
tous switcher
ouais je suis assez inquiet là je vous
ai mis il est lié à villanova on est
plutôt sur un poste un mec qui va jouer
ailier fort
qu'en comparaison qu'est ce que je peux
vous trouvez en comparaison à ses vieux
bâti demoiselle avait des comparaisons
qui vous viennent et qui vous viennent
en tête
aussi vieux que ça alors là je suis pas
forcément de quelque chose de
vraiment de vraiment actuate donc je
vais là-bas voir de quoi on y voit vous
avez le profil quoi je suis n 10 qui
doit progresser dans les pourcentages de
réussite et qui fera
qu'il sera jamais un stoppeur comme
peuvent l'être les meilleur défenseur
nba on va passer sur un troisième joueur
alors celui-là début je vous avoue que
c'était peut-être le jour que je
regardais le moins de l'équipe
et puis m'a un peu flashé et alexandre
alexandre berthod qui est le papa tu
peux gaston-berger m'a dit regarde le je
pense que c'est le peut-être le meilleur
joueur nba de l'équipe il est titulaire
depuis cette année seulement
want dance little on va regarder son
profil il est 7 heures depuis cette
année et effectivement il a des stats
qui interpelle équipes laissent tout de
suite quelqu'un qui recherche un autre
profil de swing 10 73% près du panier ce
qui est excellent et on a 36 % 3 points
ce qui est bien sachant qu'il ya un gros
volume c'est la moitié de ces tiens on a
vraiment là à mais qui finit très bien
près du panier qui est plutôt efficace
de loin avec un gros volume peau du
catch and shoot qui à mon stage de
lancers francs là on est sur un joueur
nba on va regarder ça il s'appelle
je vous mets pour pas vous faire tout le
truc de rechargement
il s'appelle brendon states et on va
regarder son profil ensemble
maintenant
je sais pas si c'est un jour que vous
connaissiez moi j'avoue que avant cette
année cinq jours que je connaissais pas
du tout
parce que comme je le disais je regarde
souvent des joueurs précis sur un
terrain pas toute l'équipe donc lui
hostile
c'est un senior alors pas super senior
juste seniors ont là ici quatrième année
avant l'an dernier jouet très peu voyez
17 minutes
c'était un petit remplaçants qui avait
voilà quatre points par match cette
année il est dans le cinq majeur et je
vous trente et une minutes il remplace
un peu numériquement djerem les robinson
earl même si c'est pas le même profil
mais voilà c'est lui qui l'a remplacé
dans le cinq majeur on est sur 12 points
donc c'est pas et c'est le quatrième je
crois plus rouvrir de l'équipe mais
comme on l'a vu
61% à 2 points avec un excellent 73%
près du cercle on à
4,2 tirs à trois points par match ce qui
est un bon volume 36% de réussite aux
tirs 82 % aux lancers francs avec de
leurs tentatives par match on a 3
rebonds 20 81 excusez moi ça c'est les
romains défensif il verse 5 passes
graufesenque style un peu de boeck peu
de ballons perdus prennent d'inspecteurs
ses 2 m 01 92 kg l'envergure on l'a pas
c'est un genre qui était plus référencer
donc on n'a pas l'envergure mais je
pense qu'il a une envergure positif on
voit l'âge allez sur le site vous le
verrez mieux que sur mon retour tweets
mais on voit un jour qui est quand même
très dessinée qui est prêt et on a
préparé du du film pour ce joueur là
alors il ya moins de d'extrait parce
qu'en fait il fait deux choses sur un
terrain il met des trois points et il
défend le plomb et on aura du coup un
petit sujet sujet philosophique là
dessus je vous prépare le film
alors est ce qu'on est sûr sur le film
de boyne slater ou pas ouais on est
passé sur le film à la cellule numéro 3
qui est la vraie note l'auteur et donc
vous allez le voir d'abord le tir à
trois points
catch and shoot les bras et sont prêts à
ça remonte très vite le geste est bien
plus propre que notre amie carmen samuel
retrouver ça ralentit et ça fait filoche
la distance
on remet au niveau des pieds elle est
clairement nba
au niveau de l'arc le tir on est bien la
vitesse c'est rapide on laisse pas le
temps ou défenseurs de venir derrière
nous il n'y a pas de mouvements
parasites
le relise est assez haut avec une belle
élévation
et ça fait filoche
actions suivantes
encore du tir à trois points on était
sûr de la transition cette fois ci
je suis dans le corner ici regardez voir
la tendance transmission les masses sont
prêtes je monte filoche alors
l'adversité mon petit m'arrive comme
michael frenzel si l'équipe de merde
qu'ils affrontent les mountain heures je
croise une équipe qui va être promu en
première division mais
par thack nous intéresse tout ce qui
nous intéresse c'est vraiment un profit
de deux tireurs donc on va pas le voir
aujourd'hui drive
l'intercités m'importe peu voilà on a un
mec tu vas mettre s'effiloche regardez
encore une fois les mâles sont prêtes je
me déplace pour être bien placé je
remonte vite la distance nba trois
points encore une petite alors on va
voir qu'il peut poser un petit dribble
quand il faut retirer pour mettre en
confiance d'un petit écran
trois points le volume de poules up est
très faible j'attendrai pas là-dessus
rennes pied d'accord par contre ce que
je peux ce que je peux apprécier cg une
feinte de tir mou défenseur soudan la
fan de terre au niveau du coeur aux
hôtes j'ai fait un petit dribble de
décalage et je me relève est donc je
vois que c'est un joueur qui peut faire
ça
ici encore un écran 22 tirs je me
repositionne je me marrais sont prêtent
de nouveau alors là la réaction n'est
pas bonne
et encore un peu le pas de propos
globalement c'est quand même on l'a vu
en quasiment exclusivement du catch and
shoot mais voilà j'aimerai toujours
j'aime toujours vous montrer
d'autres notre situation maintenant on
va parler sur la défense et
défensivement là autant moore et samuel
taurian beaucoup
parce qu'ils n'ont pas la latéralité là
vous avez un défenseur complet qui est
très agressif sur le corps qui peut
switcher on le voit pouvoir enfin je le
vois pouvoir défendre des postes 3
évidemment avec sa taille mais des
postes 4 parce qu'il est puissant des
postes de passe qui les vivent peut-être
des extérieurs enfin l'honneur pour les
moins rapides et c'est vraiment un
défenseur qui va être agressif vous
allez voir avec ses longues ses longs
bras ses mains sur le ballon et qui
bouge très bien ses pieds là on est sûr
sur un profil défensif peut-être plus
intéressant double comme c'est de la
défense je vais le mettre au ralenti
pour vraiment pouvoir tout observer on
l'a vu villanove en a pas d excellents
porteur de balle nous on a des
écoulements des celliers qui bouge assez
bien donc voilà là je me déplace
j'attaque la le ballon correctement mais
mal son actif je ne fais pas faute c'est
un joueur qui commet assez peu de fautes
et avec mon bras je vais gêner la
possession adverse
j'anticipe la page je reste focus sur le
ballon et je vais tout de suite me
positionner orienté et contesté le tir
ceinture difficile excellente défense du
début jusqu'à la fin
on cela remet une fois
à vitesse réelle regardez comme on alors
excusez moi c'est un peu la vie est ici
parce que si quelqu'un peut regarder
comment je change d'appui comme
j'attaque pour ne pas laisser le portant
de mal à l'aise et comment je suis
toujours capable de faire une aide et de
contester le tir je conteste avec les
mains ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il
peut contester main gauche main droite
au niveau des tirs elle sous suivante
encore défensivement voilà là je vais
tenir mon gars jusqu'au bout je vais le
coller au corps va pas les avoir d'
espace possible si jamais il ya un
changement de rythme il peut tenir parce
qu il bouge très bien au niveau des
petits appuis victoire fait au ralenti
beaucoup plus agressif
up l'accélération du porteur de balle
moi je peux la suivre aussi latéralement
je la mène jusqu'au bout je fais pas
faute et je conteste le tient ici je
sens dans un écran j'ai pas pris dans
l'écran je me bats j'oriente geste un
peu d espace et je conteste de façon
efficace le tir
peut se permettre celui là donc je sors
d'un écran je suis pas pris dans l'écran
on arrache witter donc je lui colle au
corps est ce que je veux pas qu'il ya
catch and shoot
sortie d'écran donc là tout de suite je
lui colle au corps je suis dans ses
appuis mais je fais pas faute elle est
très agressif vous avez choix réception
maintenant je sais que ce joueur il est
pas les au niveau de la main gauche donc
je vais l'orienter ou à droite et je
vais très vite aller le récupérer alors
il peut et élévation sur mes appuis je
suis prêt
et je comptais se tire pas mal longueur
de bras avec mon bras gauche
sans faire faute
et derrière saluer ce qui fait un bon
boxeur on récupère la possession ici je
suis en défense sur un pivot il aurait
switch avant
je boxe à vote aussi
comme à l'image de villanova au niveau
de mes appuis je suis bien placé
jeunesse pas le pivot prendre c'est pas
moi qui récupère le rebond mais je m'en
fiche l'important c'est que mon équipe
récupère le rebond est donc je sacrifie
mon corps
pour avoir la possession est parfait moi
j'aime beaucoup voulaient carrier qui
qui font passer l'équipe avant
regardez encore une fois sur les épaules
le travail de puissance en bas du corps
on voit que c'est un seigneur dans un
programme de très très haut niveau
villanova qui référence et plusieurs
fois champion là je suis dans l'aide et
en même temps je reprends alors celui-là
paraissait c'est du bonheur pardon
excusez moi donc regarder ici je crois
que c'est justin mortier battu sur le
premier pas je viens en m'interposer
dans laxe pourpre ou pour nous proposer
une aide est tout de suite je vais aller
récupérer l'attaquant direct et je vais
situe risée le robot
l'aide donc la laque s'il est coupée du
coup on a un pool apithy et tout de
suite
je viens me replacer je sécurise le
rebond
et mon équipe a la possession il
transition
ici notre ami brendan taylor donc là on
est sur une situation va avoir plusieurs
shows switch de mémoire
donc là je vais pour passer sur un pivot
je passe sur le pivot
c'est pas une menace au niveau du drive
donc je lève la main pour contester jeux
repas sur l'extérieur j'attaque au
niveau des mains je voulais me dis très
agressif nos très longues segment à
excuser moi
très agressif de très longs segments et
je pars en transition derrière
on n'a pas la fin de la transition parce
qu'on est je sais pas si marcoussis
passe voilà mais la ferme on a fait
comme défensif il m'intéresse oms l'art
fait
à vitesse réelle le switch le switch
j'attaque au niveau des mains parce que
le protège pas bien sa balle n'a pas un
excellent porteur de balle adverse et je
vais créer une transition
du coup il est là notre ami wayne d'un
skateur passeur fonctionnel petites
passes
et petits poulets à mi distance alors
voilà ce genre de truc un peu bête que
ont ils n'auraient pas forcément nba
mais c'est toujours intéressant d'avoir
de la polyvalence dans son jeu
je suis à trois points la défense va se
jeter totalement
donc la défense à la règle ici ils
anticipent la passe manipulation visuel
qu'on a là je fais semblant que je vais
transmettre à samuel ce qui est ouvert
le défenseur et tente l'interception il
est battu bonne réaction de la lecture
de jeu je prend l'intervalle poule up
ficelles
dans les statistiques
que je vais avoir ici
quatrième volume tous un terrain pour
cent on est sur 44 4% à mi distance ce
qui est de très très bons niveaux 44 4%
à mi distance on et voilà on est sûr là
quand même la partie supérieure de
l'existant être en élite
pro-choix le clip
on est en vitesse réelle
les mains sont toujours prêtes la même
feinte alors vous voyez ils sont sales
son défaut ici c'est notre ami il a il
est très peu explosif le dribbler
vraiment pas debout il n'y a pas
beaucoup de variations j'ai mené ce sera
un gaucher et peut pas proposé
grand-chose balle en main une fois qu'on
échange du drive
on est vraiment sur un profil souris ndi
chia d'autres
brasseurs fonctionnels comme tous les
mêmes de villanova je sais pas c'est le
ballon et je vais transmettre par là ils
passèrent fonctionnel
je vais pas plus que mon rôle
elle a en revanche perdu 400 ch oui je
crois
non même pas
là on est encore dans la bonne lecture
défensive voilà tout simplement vous
avez compris le profil
ici voilà je vis pictures is et je suis
à proposer une aide pour couper la passe
tout simplement l'appareil de lecture
défensive
pour la rotation
voilà c'était brendan slater je pense
s'en vouloir
sans vouloir me tromper que c'était un
coup connaissez pas forcément le joueur
c'est pas le jour le plus mise en avant
de de villanova c'est par un jour qu'on
retrouve beaucoup dans les modes pour
l'instant c'est un coup de coeur
d'alexandre ça devient aussi mon coup de
coeur je me demande si au final ce ne
sera pas mon joueur le plus au draft et
de l'équipe de villanova
si on a ce volume de tir avec cette
réussite et ce cas-ci des défensives que
je l'envisagé aussi fortement sur une
fin de premier tour encore une fois
entre 25 45 toujours le même raisin peu
un peu un peu floue avec beaucoup de
joueurs qui sont très similaires
dites moi ce que vous en pensez est ce
que vous préférez
drafté un joueur qui fait tout bien mais
pas élite quitte à ce qu'ils sont
heureux comme on l'a vu avec samuel avec
dépistage - justin moore qui est un très
beau tir d'un tireur à trois points qui
peut dribbler aussi mais qui défend
simat un peu plus limité ou vous
préférez vraiment des profils qui sont
déjà très spécialisés en acier et qui
devrait faire la même chose aurait une
bille est vraiment un jour je tire je
défends
ouais tu vois celui qui intéresse le
plus est a présenté ce soir bah ouais
parce qu'en fait je pense que c'est le
mec on est habitué à ce profil là en nba
on en a plein des mecs qui font que ça
soit tirer à trois points cédés soit
défendre mais qui font rien d'autre et
en n 6 est souvent les gens qu'on r'n'b
et kif qui tire à trois points qui
défendent uniquement il faisait plus en
juillet on a rarement des spécialistes à
part paul est vraiment les crocs
schutter mais rarement des spécialistes
qui était
simi dimensionnelles et finalement
l'adema qui se spécialise en nba parce
qu'ils sont pas assez bons pour pouvoir
dominer leurs conseillers donc voilà je
ne sais pas encore exactement si je
préfère un pur spécialiste pas en tout
cas la batellerie justin moment il ya
les tags de steinbourg pour être le
prospect le plus drafté de l'équipe et
je pense que ce sera dans tous les cas
un mec qui aura un impact positif pour
son équipe
on va terminer avec le dernier je
regardais rapidement sur twitter si
jamais il ya du et du nouveau ou pas
non non pas écouter les gens savent
qu'on est cohérent connor live je
rappelle pour ceux qui sont arrivés on a
fait le tour des prospects
nba pour la draft prochaine qui sortent
de villanova donc on récapitule justin
moore
germaine samuel et brendon spliter
point d'inspecteurs du quai pour
l'instant aucune moque vous l'aurez vu
ici en premier et qui peut peut-être
prétendre à une fin de premier tour ce
serait mérité on va finir avec le
dernier alors c'est le patron
philosophie de l'équipe
c'est le meneur de jeu ces collines
gillepsie colline gillepsie quillan
dargnat pas pu participer à la marque
pas n'est ce pas ce qu'il s'est fait les
ligaments croisés n'ont pas ligaments
croisés j'aurais pas mais c'est une
grosse blessure qui a mis fin à sa
saison de façon prématurée est donc lié
très frustré lui aussi 35e année et
c'est de lui dont on va parler
aujourd'hui donc je vais juste le temps
de faire la petite recherche sur le sur
le site on vous remettre en fait ce com
donc ton pas de conegliano street clip
pour lui parce qu'on va
on va voir que son son profil phase très
vite se résumer
et j'en parle surtout parce que c'est le
sait le patron de l'équipe c'est le
vétéran de l'équipe
alors colline guy les psys
que vous voyez ci sous votre écran
à la récréation il s'est en revanche
rien c'est mieux
22,5 en super senior de quoi encore une
fois pas très vieux pour un senior une
heure de jeu 1 mètre 90 83 kg donc en
meneur de jeu d'assez grande taille
développer physiquement on voit au
niveau de la musculature qui les a c'est
fini il a
cinq saisons on l'a dit super senior
blessé l'an dernier nokia pas pu faire
c'est pour ça que vous avez que 20
matches mais ça un énorme temps de jeu
il est titulaire depuis maintenant
quatre ans il a toujours eu des
standards un peu j'allais pleurer même
pourcentage on a une dizaine de points
entre 11 cette année 16 points bas qui
par choix un bon début de saison ce qui
va nous intéresser les volumes à trois
points 40 % la première année soit un
petit volume 38% 36% 38% 43% avec 8,3
tentative par match ce qui est
absolument énorme 43% à 3 points avec un
aussi gros volumes entente peu de
lancers francs on n'a pas un jour très
explosif par contre on est fiable quand
on y va on prend des rebonds à l'image
de toute l'équipe on va voir alors pas
de clip de pâques soit mais il fait
aussi du box haute il va participer il
fait le sale travail 3 4 passes
décisives
avec les participations jamais été
sait-on jamais explosé parce que on a
une équipe très collectif qui fait
beaucoup tourner le ballon on n'a pas un
vrai meneur de jeu de pick and roll
c'est pas le jeu de villanova par contre
c'est un joueur qui perd pas de ballons
1,5 temps dover pas match donc pour tous
e.on a dit 3 4 passes décisives que
c'est un ratio supérieur à 2 ce qui en
nba et très bien que vous avez redresse
un peu supérieure à 2 août est dans une
bonne moyenne billets est aussi là
dessus de la moyenne quand vous avez un
ratio supérieur à 3 loi n'est pas l'un
des trois buts dans l'élite de la nba
excusez moi pour s'est brouillée à côté
c'est ma vie de famille en même temps on
est vers le bureau une virgule quatre
styles par ammann 15 jours vous allez
voir est une teigne défensive maintenant
il faut avancer
coline gillepsie donc gros défaut gros
flop 43 8% près du panier ce qui est
très très faible parce que c'est pas un
athlète ils mentent pas oh c'est un
joueur fiable de battre 4 mais voilà qui
équipa finisseur près du cercle donc ça
c'est vraiment pas bon on a très peu de
shoot à mi distance alors vous voyez
même pourcentage près du cercle un
joueur qui tente très peu près par
clélie est pas bon très peu aimée
distance il est efficace 44,4 % c'est un
joueur qui va se créer tout fait hier on
poulpe et le reste deux tiers 70 % donc
c'est quasi que ça en fait c'est du
trois points il ay est très bon cette
intéressante en 60 % des européens 64%
des trois points son site une passe
décisive ça veut dire que 1,3 point sur
trois c'est lui dise le crès ampoules up
car il va pas souvent aux lancers francs
mais quand il y va il est efficace
on complète ici pour confirmer
près du panier on n'est vraiment pas bon
on est dans le ski tu fais là vous voyez
pas forcément très bien là dessus mais
maintenant vous voyez plutôt que c'est
trop gros par dont on est sûr la moyenne
passe passe bassin billets par contre ce
taux à 3 points on est sur la moyenne
haute avec un gros volume c'est l'heure
du clip
on ici qu'il qu'il est psy
ça s'est lancé ici
donc premier point d'entrée la défense
c'est une petite teigne on a encore
contre syracuse jeu les saignées au
niveau du clip ce monsieur là vous voyez
les bohèmes peu dit jimmy le papa il a
90 ans ses fils de 20 ans il n'y a pas
de problème je suis pas là pour juger
qu alinghi les psys donc défensivement
une petite elle très agressif ça bouge
bien ça se fait pas trop prendre dans
les grands jours le switch on va rien
lâcher on va tenir
et on va aller chercher l'interception
surf est ici
dans l'écran je passe bien à travers
l'écran je switche l'anticipation c'est
un joueur qui est très intelligent qui
fait toujours la bonne action et on va
prendre interceptions encore une
séquence défensive de collines dit les
psys up l'anticipation au niveau de
l'interception sur une passe qui est
trop facile la bonne passe et le dunk et
derrière on pousse un petit peu
l'adversaire pour parce qu'on est quand
même je râle profil assez teigneux
pour bien expliquer que ce match on va
le gagner voilà on peut être un petit
coup au passage ça fait toujours du bien
andré gars de villanova ici on tient au
contact d'un ailier sage au rck et
puissant qui est réaliste on tient à une
corde bien développer leur en haut en
bas aussi qui est très frustrant donc en
nba on peut le voir switcher sur donc il
peut défendre effectivement des
extérieurs non peuvent rajouter sur des
petit ailier et ça ça va être assez
intéressant pour une franchise qui livre
pour vous le donner à une projection dès
maintenant on va avoir fait remettre un
troisième meneur 2e 3e honneur on a du
sens son compère hearted iacono qui fait
des piges en nba c'est le même principe
c'est le même style de joueur c'est un
joueur qui aura toujours un impact
positif sur un terrain peut être dans
une équipe qui va pourtant de space in
extérieur avec des ailiers qui porte le
ballon il peut être rentré dans une
rotation
mais voilà ça devrait pas douter puisque
ça l'échangeur de rotation qui aura
quelques contrats et qui en europe
serait excellent on l'a vu le trois
points il n'y a pas d'hésitation geste
et rapide le geste est précis on peut
tirer d'assez loin derrière un écran
ça fait filoche
donc aura trois points une feinte un
petit dribble je voulais dit alors que
les joueurs j'aime bien celle ci y est
les joueurs qui vont être capables de
l'irak la aux autres qu'on se leurre
fait ici
il saute dans la dans la feinte de tir
un petit dribble jeter face tu es dans
mon auto tirs à trois points ouvert et
ça fait ficelle
il ressemble un petit mâconnais l'ouest
et c'est le jour de grâce et les
meilleurs vétérans une civière
toujours bien coiffée toujours une tête
d'orange et qui provoque des passages en
force des interceptions qui sont
agressifs qui par le mal qui tu vois là
qu'ils ont toujours un impact positif
petite gemma connaît la ti diacono
payton pritchard qui lui pour le coup et
au site était aussi un très gros shooter
sa qualité de première l'adfh en attaque
c'est vraiment de mettre détient en une
pièce ce jour là hier c'est pour cela
qu'à rousseau aussi bon qu'à rentrer
plus athlétiques mais voilà c'est ce
jour là tu lui mets à côté d'un ailier
qui porte le ballon forcément lebron
james mais aux clippers avec du tir
yanis forcément on mettait des ailiers
kuyt ou van équipe forte et le ballon à
lille peut vraiment existé là dedans on
voit monter morize qui est à côté de
jokic c'est pareil c'est des joueurs qui
sont prêts qui sont expérimentés qui
n'ont pas coûté très cher et qui font
tout iront toujours un impact positif
pour leur équipe ici on lit bien au
niveau du démarquage et on se met sur le
côté voilà je vous ai dit j'ai pas
préparé beaucoup de clips de guy l'ipsi
parce que ça se résume très rapidement
ce qui fait assez il bouge bien y met du
contact il anticipe bien il y bien les
défenses
c'est un bon tireur c'est un passeur
correct pas pris de clips de passe mais
c'est un passeur correct c'est un
haendel
assez limité parce que le premier pas
est pas explosif parce que le la
verticalité pas bonne non plus on n'est
pas foutu sur le changement de direction
alors on est vraiment sûr du soulier
andy sur un poste d'extérieur
c'était le dernier jour qu'on avait donc
on a fini ce petit tour d'horizon sur
sur les prospects de villanova que
l'épilepsie si les prix au second tour
je pense
je le vois bien être un draft idée
signer très rapidement
un tour et contracte wa trucs comme ça
si jamais ça fait pour une bière en
europe il sera excellent en europe il
n'y a aucun problème là dessus
chaque club européen sera très content
d'avoir son collier les psys et je pense
que c'est un joueur qui est le tueur a
toujours un truc positif est ce que ça
peut être mieux encore castrateur d'un
deuxième cinq nba je pense même pas que
ce sera dans quatre enfants j'ai encore
calé en deuxième ça canebiers je pense
même pas
ça va vraiment être
pardon excusez moi à souilhe ndi ça va
vraiment être un joueur qui va tromper
szczesny qui voiture faire la bonne
décision
avery bradley par exemple peut être un
très bon et un très bon exemple de ça il
peut jouer aussi post 2 g les lives et
les meneurs à villanova même à 90 tu
peux très bien jouer poste de
donc
voilà je pense que s'il joue c'est qu'il
y aura une blessure quelque chose comme
ça il rentrera dans la rotation les fans
l'adorent ont tout de suite et il peut
il pourra dépanner
chose qu'au mieux au mieux c'est ça pour
lui c'est vraiment sorti devant mettait
trois points et espérer avoir un
deuxième contrat et voilà c'est un jour
qui sera toujours apprécié qui sera
toujours positif
mais qui sera jamais un créateur
principal one situe leur engament à mes
jeux
là ce moment si vous avez des questions
n'hésitez pas n'hésitez pas dans le chat
on peut parler d'autre chose que
villanova j'espère que j'ai fait
découvrir des joueurs intéressants
au niveau des clips c'était assez
qualitatif que la sonabel à tour donné
et puis si on voulait pas d'autres
joueront pour les autres jours sans
problème j'ai encore un petit peu de
temps avant d'aller me coucher je suis
hyper fun je suis performant en vacances
donc on est là pour ça je passe
maintenant sur twitter pour partie et
pas des petites marques twitter mais
mais voilà je suis là pour le moment
en tout cas merci encore à tous un
d'être sur ce stream avec nous ce soir
du coup avec moi là parce qu'elle n'est
pas là on se revoit avec alan vendredi
prochain on fera du joueur nba français
de prospects and see et on fera comme
entre peut-être à parler de nos board
respectifs on a commencé à en discuter
sur nos conversations privées
donc voilà on se rejoindra mais en tout
cas vous êtes toujours fidèle au poste
écoulée
j'espère que ce format là vous plaît
tout cash envergure on essaie de le
diversifier d'ailleurs petit plus pour
les copains de toujours pas de mal j'en
profite sur notre site
incroyable la connexion qui a l'air
c'est pas le site vous avez
il est dernier podcast sortie quel
français pour la draft vous avez un peu
de caste qui est arrivé chez kojak bas
du jour notre chaîne youtube vous avez
des articles deux articles qui sont
sortis de très très très très bonne
qualité cet article que j'ai pour lire
l'heure globalement c'est tout est très
bien forcément osé partir de malt ldquo
paraissent je suis
et je prends plaisir à l'ailière mans en
tant que spectateur mais ces deux là un
cinq majeur dans un pacte web c'est
julien braillard et n'hésitait pas les
lits follow sur twitter qui qu'il a
rédigé sur les prospects simplement un
côté de la pac twelve qui est une amie
johr la coiffure s abstiennent piano dit
bill walton je vous louvre vous présente
cinq joueurs dont parle pas forcément
installe entre huy arizona qui peuvent
être des frères ou nba dont vous avez
richardson d'orégon vous avez d'aller à
terry arizona kid un grand meneur moi
j'aime beaucoup les grands honneurs de
mai 0 88 kg da silva colorado et actes
mollo voici qui sont des ailiers lié
fort
un peu vétérans et spencer jones qui est
fan club dans notre notre équipe
envergure qui est un poste 3 très long
et enfants pivot mohamed khaïr
washington state qui est un gros volume
n'hésitez pas à l'afp article avec
ensuite
des petites préférences de styles des
petits bonus
il ya la deuxième qui écrit par alan
alan millions
sur jalle engine qui est un pivot
freshman
c'est un pivot freshman qui étaient très
attendus comme top 5 qui a annonc tout
le monde qui a été reclassifiées il joue
à memphis avec que tu peux dire à
dahouët et et money bates qui perd un
prospect tricoter pour de l'année
suivante 8 peut aller la draft cette
année et ils se demandent est ce qu'un
train pivot athlétique physique ne
suffit pas au top 5 de draft nba donc on
a l'habitude maintenant des pivots qui
qui tire qui peuvent défendre les
extérieurs là on a vraiment un vrai
pivot à l'ancienne qui est une bête
athlétique qui dunk qui défend qui
compte dix autres partout avec des bras
très défini alors que il avait 17 ans là
dessus est-ce que ça suffit pour
maintenant être pris dans le top 5 nous
malades à bonal prennent alliés sur la
draft et sûre sur les profils c'est
vraiment hyper intéressant et c'est
travailler
il donne quoi le frangin artiaco nova
equity le roe développement c'est le
même boucle ryan ou s et le même moule
c'est alors il est moi je trouve moins
bon pour l'instant millet encore plus
jeune je sais plus
s'il en deuxième ou troisième année
qu'on qui les psys partir à la fin de
l'année ce sera lui le titulaire de
l'équipe
voilà il est en développement je trouve
un peu moins bon pour l'instant
mais ce sera ce sera un bon joueur de
basket qui peut-être en hausse en europe
qu'en nba une charte il a connu le grand
frère pour répartir aussi en europe s'il
ne s'apprend pas son expérience j league
et l mcba merci beaucoup tu découvres
footing avec nous
bah merci écoute de nous de nous suivre
j'espère que que le contenu peuple
j'espère qu'on est assez conne est
explicite sans être chiant cons et qu'on
donne ça de façon
assez assez fun que tu sais que tu
arrives à protéger ça avec nous cette
application dsit pas on n'est pas des
les professionnels à wasquehal aux
scouts proméo mais quand même sur plus
une équipe d'amateurs mais voilà
j'espère que que tu prends plaisir avec
nous à découvrir lundi et à t'intéresser
à nos à nos jeunes pépites et puis enfin
la de l'arctique vous avez les secours
et porte un chaque jour son article
scouting report avec des joueurs très
jeunes scouts henderson des vétérans
ancien en champagne et puis aussi des
européens on a ici fedor ou beach
du monténégro j'allais pas reconnu le
drapeau donc voilà voilà voilà voilà bon
bah écoutez je reste encore deux trois
minutes le ciel est question qui va
signer en bas on va tout simplement
basculer par la suite ah mais je vous
montre des articles en fait l'amateur
jeu mou des articles depuis tout à
l'heure et en fait
vous avez ma tête c'est beaucoup moins
intéressant alors excusez moi
excusez moi ici l'article georges djen
djen le pivot comme on le voit très
dessinée effectivement qu'on visite à
dessiner que vous aviez sa calvitie
c'était peu représentatif de ce que je
voulais montrer
l'article sur l'app actuelle ici avec la
belle tête de john terry et puis là sur
le côté
tous les scouts signé pour deux
disponibles
voilà
bon bah écoutez je vois qu'à pas
je vais pas de capote trop d'autres
questions l' écoute mars à tokyo ce
tilleul c'était par claude à voir
jusqu'au bout effectivement j'espère que
ça vous a plu nous on va se retrouver
bas sur les réseaux tous les jours vous
pouvez me retrouver sur mon propre
réseau twitter alors je vous montre ça
sent fort de la mauvaise pub
rapidement si si jamais
ça vous intéresse moi je me trouve pas
et finalement c'est passé pas très
pertinent s'en fiche vous me retrouver
sinon dimanche donc après demain pour
pour un autre ce petit gars les portes
je pense que ce sera soit samuel du coup
souhaite steve moore gérant lequel je
sors d'abord mais pour compléter les
missions qu'on a là vous allez nous
retrouver dans un podcast sur un des
joueurs de cette ligne qui devrait
sortir dans la semaine dans laquelle
j'ai pu participer j'ai la chance de
participer avec nico à l'année alexandre
et puis voilà globale tous les jours
chauds envergure un article à scouting
les portes des fois un peu de casse des
foins live youtube des fonds un stream
merci encore d'être d'être présent de
soutenir envers la cure les pions se dit
à tout bientôt des bisous à tous passé
une bonne fin de soirée prenez soin de
vous de bonnes fêtes à vous à tout
bientôt tiens